how are you doing today
i'm doing pretty well can't can't
complain uh
so first i guess good morning from here
uh in l.a um i'm in l.a too
oh well there we go so it's you know a
sunny day for both of us
during the pandemic i've been asking
everyone the same two first questions
which is
uh what tv series would you love to
guest star on
succession i hear that answer a lot
fantastic show what movie or movies
do you think you've seen the most robert
altman's nashville
and mean girls okay
those are two great choices thank you um
jumping into why i get to talk to you
today what was it about the script
the story what was it about this project
that said i want to do this
it really intimidated me um it's a you
know it was
the the world of social media um
is something that scares me so much i
don't
think about it very often and that isn't
this i don't even mean scary like i
think it's bad
i just don't understand it um and it
feels like an unbelievably powerful tool
that i don't know how to use properly
um and um it's like it feels like i have
like a
samurai sword hanging in my kitchen and
like
and there's an invader at the door and i
have to figure out how to defend myself
with a with this giant heavy samurai
sword that i've never picked up before
you know it's sort of the way i feel
about social media um
and uh um and so because of that
i you know i always want to do things
that scare me um and make me explore
parts of myself or parts of my world
that i
don't think about because i don't want
to um and
uh and this movie did that for me um and
so that drew me in and then
but really the thing that drew me in was
wanting to work with geo really badly
and wanting to learn about acting from
andrew and
and that and um uh so that was that
those things for me and too
listen i think andrew's a fantastic
actor but i also think he's very brave
in this
because there's a scene where he's
running around hollywood boulevard
naked wearing like this underwear penis
thing
and i'll be honest i don't think i could
do that it's very brave
do you when what was your reaction when
you heard he was doing this
or you know because it's it's pretty
ballsy
you know i think that the um this thing
happens with actors all the time
which is you get a script and you read
scenes like it happened for me on
stranger things like
i read the scene where i was going to be
like tied up in a russian prison or
whatever
and i was like oh yeah i can't wait to
do that and then you get to the day in
which you're doing it you're like wait
you really have to tie me to a chair
like i don't want to do it um and um
because like it sounded so fun on camera
it's like oh cool my character is a
black eye
and then you're like oh wait you have to
paint on a black eye
every day and i have to put a contact
lens in like jesus
um you know so the reality is of
something and the idea of something is
really different but
and that's always really hard for me and
i can totally imagine reading the script
if
if frankie had to do that i can imagine
you'd be like oh my god i can't wait to
do that i'm going to run naked through
hollywood boulevard it's going to be
great
and then like the day would arrive which
i had to do it and i would be like no
way
um but i don't even think andrew's hands
shook i mean
he's he's so brave and he was so deeply
in the zone of this character while we
were making this movie that i
i i mean i i i didn't i didn't even hear
his voice quiver or his handshake
um you know it was all about the movie
and and it was an important scene for
the movie and so it was going to happen
well there's also and i could be wrong
about this but it almost feels like you
were filming
real moments like with the with the art
poster on the wall
where when you were filming that scene
like were those people that were
standing there real because i got the
vibe they were
um you know in i won't tell you when it
was real and when it wasn't
sometimes in this movie it was real and
sometimes it wasn't um
and that was kind of gia's idea was to
mix real moments in with contrived
moments in order to create a real
experience um and to me it was very
effective
oh 100 um there's a line in the movie
that i really liked which is
andrew says you want to make art or
chase affirmation from
faceless strangers and i think that
represents so many people online and you
were talking about social
media uh can you sort of talk about that
that so many people are just looking for
likes rather than actually spending
their time
creating art yeah i mean i think that
that's to me that's what this movie is
really about
um you know i i like it it is in some
ways about social media but to me it's
actually about
what can happen if you make people who
make art for years and years and years
that nobody likes
right um always make art that comes from
their soul
um and the only motivation to make it is
because they believe in it like you know
if i mean if you take an artist like
alice neil right she was a painter
and she was never successful in her
lifetime um and she made these beautiful
portraits because she had to make them
um but once you make art that becomes
popular that starts to make money
there's this other motivation to make
art which is not
i want to make this because i have to
make it and it's in my soul but it's i
want to make it because there's demand
for it and it could
money could be made off of that and
that's both money for me and money for
all these
other people uh money for the company
that hired me money for
my friends money for you know and so
keeping
track of your motivation and of why you
make things
because that's a very quick path to
start making bad art and even
potentially dangerous art
um like art that isn't good for people
um so
i that's to me that's what this movie is
really about so i think that's a great
quote to pull up because
andrew said that i mean link says that
and then
what does he do he does exactly the
thing he warned not
do um so so i think you hit the nail on
the head there with that question
my i'm almost out of time with you
listen i'm a huge fan of stranger things
uh and it feels like stranger things
season four has been filming for 17
years
when do you actually finish filming uh
the series
it feels that way to me too i'm not
allowed to tell you when we finish
filming but i can tell you that like
though it's been forever because we've
had
so much time the like level of effort
interest and detail that the duffer
brothers have had the time to put into
this these scripts
um um and that the actors have had the
time to think about their characters
and like it is gonna be awesome and i'm
so proud of the work that everyone is
doing
um and i'm i can't wait for people to
see the season um and i it's been a long
wait but i i think it will be worth it
uh i just heard netflix just announced
this morning uh this fear street trilogy
what can you tease about this thing
because it sounds really cool it's in
three different time periods
well i don't know i haven't gotten my
netflix brief yet
um on what i can and can't tease but i
can say this it's got a lot of people in
it that i love
um uh sadie sync is in it um and
and my friend fred fred is in it um who
uh um who is fred heckinger who's an
amazing actor
um has been one of my best friends since
high school um and i
um and it was really fun to make and lee
is an amazing director
um that i i cannot wait to to to see
these movies i haven't seen them
um but um but i'm i'm really excited
yeah um just so you know they announced
this three different films three
different time periods
all connected to one story uh and it
sounds really interesting and i can't
believe that it was all made without
anyone knowing
i i also can't believe it i mean i when
you see the movie you'll understand
the reason that i'm answering these
questions the way that i'm answering
them
and and it will all make sense to you i
i
i can't really say more than that i
completely understand um
listen congrats on everything that's
going on with you uh
and wish you nothing but the best stay
safe and healthy um
thank you you too